want to be happy build a life not just
the business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only esther perel
everybody has a relationship history
everybody grew up with people that were
either there for you
or less there for you or not there for
you at all
everybody either wish they had gotten
more attention or less attention
you understand some of us got a little
too much of something and some of us got
too much neglect
and absence of something
and everybody here has narratives about
relationships
meaning
you can all ask yourself the questions
did you grow up in a family
that talked about relationship as
something central in your life
and saw it as important it was a
relational orientation to life versus a
task orientation to life
it was one in which you were told people
are there for you you can trust them if
you have a problem go and talk to them
or were you told this is you you have
your own legs to stand on nobody is
going to come in and solve your problems
and does that influence the way you
actually either collaborate or compete
because you think that people are there
for you or because
they're you don't think so
basically were you raised for autonomy
or where you raised for loyalty
it's not an either or it's an emphasis
where you race for interdependence or
where you race for self-reliance
and given that many of you are
entrepreneurs the answers are very
interesting about that where you got
your messages
and what are the narratives and the
beliefs that you have created about that
and here's the most important thing
don't ever think for a minute that your
relationship dowry doesn't come with you
to work
it doesn't stop at the door of the
building where you go to work
when you talk about relationship
accountability when you talk about trust
and all of those things go back
and find your story so that you can see
how you can edit it and write new pages
to it i think inbound is about
innovation and about the future of the
workplace right i would not have been
here 10 years ago there would not have
been a key note on relationships at a
professional conference at a business
conference it would have been about
kpi's performance efficiency bottom line
you name it it wouldn't have been about
what is considered soft skills and the
soft skills are now the bottom line and
those soft skills for a long time were
considered feminine skills which you
know what happens to those they're
idealized in principle and discarded in
reality
so
this importance of saying you know
relationships at this point are really a
undergoing a change but they're also
threatened they've become more and more
polarized and people are less and less
able to actually manage the complexities
of relationships
and
pay attention to that the quality of
your relationships determines the
quality of your life pay attention to it
in work don't think it's a side product
don't just do it when there is a crisis
and
recognize the importance of
relationships in your life it is a it's
an interesting thing how because
everybody seems to live it it's never
actually treated like a proper topic of
inquiry
rather than just kind of you know we're
all we're all doing it you know it's not
true and that would be the first message
including here talk to strangers
leave your phone on the table when you
go to the bathroom when you're at lunch
with somebody you know call home and
thank the people who actually made it
possible for you to be here put this
notion of my relationships and my
accountability into my relationships
really front and center it will make a
huge difference in your life in your
teams and in your workplace altogether
most of the people today are going to
have two or three relationships in their
adult marriages or just relationships
committed relationships marriages commit
i could say marriages but let's say in
europe so many of us don't marry so it's
a committed relationships most of us are
going to have two or three committed
relationships in our lifetime due to
divorce due to death various things
some of us are going to do it with the
same person
i have had probably three marriages to
the same man wow not because we divorced
or anything but because over 30 years we
have had to redefine ourselves
to restructure everything that you do in
companies you know to change our brand
what works for five years is not going
to work for the next that's right but
work when we are just two is not the
same as what works when we are four
right what works when we're in our
twenties isn't the same as when we are
in our fifties what works when we have
this type of career is not the same as
now you know um
and i think that
the very principles that you apply to
companies today flexibility
fluidity the ability to reinvent itself
to redefine itself to manage
tradition and innovation
is really what has to enter into all
modern love that's what coupled them is
about those who can do it do it with
each other and the other ones do it by
finding a new person
so what's the ideal relationship moving
forward in our
it's this it's uh it's you sit every
once in a while and you say how we doing
what are the strengths between us
what you know it's i actually think
people should have
do different commitment ceremonies in
the course of a marriage really yes i
think that every few years or every year
they should have a little summit or they
should have a little whatever they want
to call it they could have a ceremony a
kind of where are we at checking in how
are we doing what has been good in our
life what could we do better what could
we do differently are we doing right by
our children are we giving you know are
we meeting some of our important needs
at this point what has changed for us
we've just been sick we've just lost a
parent we've just lost a child what's
changing in our life and to actually
address this head-on what the problem is
in modern couples is that most of the
big topics are addressed when there is a
crisis
rather than when actually things are
good when you're calm when you come of
course you have less incentive to change
when things are good
but you have less creativity to change
when things are bad same for companies
same for couples one of the things that
happens when couples are in conflict is
that by definition conflict creates a
contraction it stiffens there is no
flexibility there is no nuance there is
no possible there is just categorical so
people instantly go into the you're
always late you always do this you never
care about what i say you never show up
when i need you to and it becomes
factual as if it really is the case and
one of the very important things to
understand in couples communication is
the fact that a lot of what is presented
as fact is actually an
intensification of someone's experience
i feel like you never show up that's not
the same as you never show up
and to not shift my feelings to
pseudo-factual talk when you say to
somebody you never the first thing
they're gonna do is give you an example
of the last time when they did just to
prove you wrong just to dismantle the
whole thing you never clean up you never
pick up the kids you never write to me
you never called me what about that time
and they'll show you the one and only
sometimes but it is the one and only
time to refute your theory of them
because who can take on such a
condemnation you know full package
condemnation so the best thing you can
say is it feels like that happens all
the time and probably you don't do it
nearly as often as i think you do but in
this moment i don't see the other stuff
in this moment i just feel like it's
just so
annoying you know and you're allowed to
be angry you're allowed to be pissed but
you're not allowed in the same way to
think that your experience therefore is
the reality or the truth it is the truth
of your experience but not necessarily
the truth of what happens when there is
a crisis when something breaks out
suddenly people launch into
conversations that they've never had and
they are finally grappling with the
level of honesty about this but in the
midst of so much pain that was and
resentment anger yeah confusion pain
rage disappointment romantic frustration
you name it like could we do better can
we do it sooner can we have the courage
to have some of the difficult
conversations before we were in the
midst of a crisis you make a quick note
to yourself what's one thing that you
need to do at least before you see me
again
meaning you have a year
it's a long time my patients they have a
week
you know or they have to tell me by 36
hours i did x or i did y
you know what is one thing that you
could do
concretely that doesn't have to be
qualified and excused and defended and
and explained the way that would bring a
different balance to where you put the
best parts of you what were some of the
main messages that you grew up with
around relationships at home in school
in your community
where you told relationships are central
they matter they nurture you people are
trustworthy they want to help you if you
have a problem reach out where you rest
for loyalty certainty is the enemy of
change
meaning
that most people are capable of more
than what they are and what they do but
they don't always know it
and that
strength model that resiliency model
accompanies me a lot
so when you can always be right
but it's not difficult to be right and
alone
that's what happens in many
relationships you stick to your thing
and you think you're right but you write
and alone
the second thing that is really
fundamental fundamental for me in
thinking about relationships
is that it is not the content that
matters
nearly as much as the form
do you understand that
meaning yesterday not beautiful
conversation we had at night you could
have thought that it was about this
story versus that story when in fact it
was about what was underlying and what
was the form that was underlying what
are the three main hidden issues that
exist below a lot of relationship
dynamics and relationship conflict is
either about power and control
either about closeness and care
either about respect and recognition
it didn't matter what the stories were
that people were telling what matters
that each one wanted their story to be
recognized and each one wanted the other
one to do it first
form is what
if you have a certain pattern a certain
model you will find that you can talk
about green peas in south korea or the
next investment you're going to make and
the tone will be the same
get off the subject and watch what
you're doing and use these three hidden
the dimensions to see where is the
problem so how does someone regain trust
then because we were talking about this
earlier how do we regain trust and
regain
open communication if someone's been
unfaithful or just hurting them for a
couple of years in a relationship and
you feel like it's not working
you know it's interesting because you're
asking me this and yet you as an amazing
role model have spoken about some of
your own experiences of abuse so you
know this question how do you let
someone touch you
come near you
not feel like they're going to harm you
understand the difference between caring
touch and hurtful touch
allowing yourself to experience pleasure
again allowing yourself to surrender
without thinking that while you're not
on guard
nothing bad is gonna happen really
challenging right okay but it's that
same
trajectory right it's like
you begin to you first of all you're you
well in this case your child versus
adult but you you you
you hope
that it's not because one person hurts
you that you lose your faith in humanity
you hope that you know that there are
people who are not harmful that they
really are good people that care and
love
you
probably trust with your eyes more open
it doesn't have the same naivety when
people start out and they have a lot of
good will and they give a lot of benefit
of the doubt and they make a point of
thanking the other person acknowledging
what they do validating how they feel
the the experience of being seen is part
of the building of the trust the
experience of being known the experience
of having somebody who has deep
attention on you and is curious
fundamentally curious to get to know you
that kind of penetration that is highly
erotic as in you feel alive you feel you
feel vibrant it's not in the sexual
sense of the word erotic
this is what the charge that people feel
you perk up you sit like this
complacency looks like this
that's the position it's like whatever
you know you don't notice anymore you
don't really pay attention you start to
feel like you're a function you know you
are defined by the tasks that you do and
no longer by the person that you are
it's a multitude of those things that
ultimately create
step by step a disconnect
you know um that's what i mean by
complacency it's not it's um it's a less
affair like that you know alessia lee
where you you don't notice things you
don't acknowledge them and
the flip side of that is that you
basically just acknowledge the negative
you know you love you become completely
distorted in your perception you have a
big bias whatever is good is a given
there's nothing to say about it and
whatever is bad can be amplified to the
end degree give each other a lot of
individual space not everything needs to
be shared people have different passions
different interests different friends
and they need those separate spaces to
exist
um admiration i think is huge
because admiration is also that you kind
of really see the otherness of the other
person
don't try to make your partner into one
person for everything
there is no such a person
find multiple sources of connection of
intimacy of friendship so that you can
have a group of people support you and
don't have one person who has to be
there for you for everything especially
when you're in the dumpster
we used to have a village of people to
do that now we just expect one person to
be the villager yes yes yes one person
for the whole village that that is that
is a unique it is and and then we're
upset when they don't fulfill the
mandate and that's the more import like
i can't talk to you you're not
supportive of me you're not excited for
me
excuse me find other people right you
know i can't be everything for you no
exactly no relationships that work well
are relationships that really straddle
the two fundamental sets of human needs
it's the need for connection and the
need for freedom it's that relatedness
thing you need to be able to have
a base but you also need and you have to
you need to be able to have belonging
but you also need a space for becoming
so that's the place where you can
express yourself where you can change
where you can grow if you can straddle
the anchor in the waves you have a very
good system same thing on the vertical
you need stability but you also need
change you need hierarchy order
discipline any parent knows that you
manage discipline and love you need a
structure you need organization but if
you have too much of it nothing can move
and you get rigid and you fossilize and
if you have too little of it you go into
this regulation and you go chaotic it is
that dance between these polarities
where people find their bliss what
people do look this is we want one
partner today to give us everything that
involves stability and security and
everything that involves playfulness and
mystery okay that's the grand ideal okay
i want to be cozy with you and i want to
have an edge and i want you to surprise
me and i want you to be familiar and i
want you to give me continuity and i
want you to give me novelty that's it as
if it's a
right and no victoria's secret is going
to solve that yeah right so then it
becomes what is desire desire is to own
the wanting
if you ask people a question that goes
like this i turn myself off when i turn
myself off by
not you turn me off when and what turns
me off is
you're gonna hear i turn myself off when
i do emails when i spend too many time
on the phone when i over eat when i
don't exercise when i have bad
bad days at work when i don't feel
confident when i numb myself when i feel
dead when i don't feel contriving when
i'm not alive you will really hear that
it has very little to do with sex
and when you ask people i turn myself on
when or by i awaken my desires
not you turn me on when and what turns
me on is which is i you responsible for
my wanting right what people will talk
to you about is when i'm in nature when
i'm connected with my friends when i get
to do my sports when i play music when i
listen to music
it's stuff that gives me pleasure
that is alive that is vibrant that is
vital that is erotic in the full sense
of the word as life force if you want to
change the other
change yourself
if relationships are made up of
interdependent parts
if you change one part and consistently
non-contingently hold on to it sooner or
later the other one has to adapt
to something
but the same thing would be true and
this is something i do want to say
particularly in light of the
conversations we're having at this
moment where people are saying why
should i help you
you go figure out your stuff you know
you men you people you know
when you help the other person change or
grow it is enlightened self-interest
don't think you're just doing this for
them
if we are interdependent parts if they
change so does your life if you were
advising uh someone that just got into a
relationship in the last month or a
recent relationship they just got into
and they're watching or listening
would you advise them to have certain
conversations early on once they realize
they're going to be you know committed
to each other or give it a shot and be
monogamous with each other
would you tell them to start talking
about these things even when it's the
puppy love and it's the romance time
is that the time to talk about it when
do you talk about it that's that's a
fantastic question because in the
beginning you don't want to talk about
it because you don't want to jinx it
yeah and then you don't want to talk
about it because you didn't talk about
it before
exactly and then you're looking for the
right moment to talk about it and then
when you bring it up later the person
says have you been thinking about this
the whole time and you haven't told have
you done anything so now i'm already
suspicious why are you
look i think the simplest thing for the
difficult conversations is to have them
be integrated as part of the whole thing
when you talk about previous
relationships you ask have you been
heartbroken have you ever left somebody
in a shitty way
have you ever lied to somebody have you
cheated on someone have you been cheated
on
have you ever made up with someone who
cheated on you have you ever been able
to you know
do you have trust issues about in
general you know because of your mother
because of your father not even because
of your own experiences
you know
infidelity is a conversation like you
talk about intimacy like you talk about
other relationships i mean if you go in
a business
experience and you're with a new partner
you probably would say what have been
your experiences with other co-founders
you know what have been your other
experiences with business partners have
you had good experiences is this
experience sitting on the on the top of
a bad divorce from before
you know in general whoever you choose
next is always chosen by default in
relation to the one that preceded right
anyway so it is right there
and then you say listen and this is not
because i'm thinking about it or because
i want to do it it's because i actually
want to get to know you and i want to
get you and i want you to get to know me
then is the conversation too when you
love what is your experience about
exclusivity
you know many people it's find it is the
romantic ideal makes that question
forbidden because once i have found the
one and only and that is the one for
whom i'm willing to delete my apps and
that is the one for whom i'm stopped by
looking you are now the person that has
so captivated me that i stopped
searching that's it my fomo is taken
care of
doesn't matter that another thousand
people out there you got me you know how
am i going to then say to you you know
what on occasion i still think about
this one or that one of my ex or i have
attractions
this is normal we choose not to act on
them monogamy is a practice
it's not a dogma and it's not natural
it's a choice
it's a practice that we exercise because
we choose a certain relationship that we
want to be in if you think that trust is
it will never happen again
and until i know that it will never
again i can't trust you
then you will never trust
because trust as rachel butzman says
beautifully is an active
responsible engagement with the unknown
it's a leap of faith
if you have to know before
then you will never trust
the act of trust is the engagement with
that which you can't know for sure
that's the definition
and if you to stay or to go is not
dependent just on that
because you may have been betrayed about
certain things while a lot of other
things were staying in place
it's very contextual
and so you think you have a history with
betrayals of before what is this the
first time what has happened you know
how the most important thing when you
have been hurt or harmed
this is what tyranna was talking about
yesterday is the fact that somebody
comes and acknowledges that they have
hurt you
nothing is more important to the healing
than that the biggest turn on is
confidence right confidence you ask
people when do you find yourself most
drawn to your partner
every description has to do with when
they're in their element when they're on
stage when they're with when when when
they're doing their sport when they when
they are radiant when they are in their
studio on the piano on the horse you
name it it's when they are in their
element i.e
they don't need me to take care of them
they're not depressed and down and
lonely and sad they're not needy they
don't need me because desire is about
wanting you
love is also about needing you you never
fight
over the thing that you think you're
fighting over or talk or argue whatever
it is it's not the content
it's rarely the content
if i think that you don't care about me
no matter what we talk about the fact
that that's what i think is going to
permeate how i interpret what you're
saying
if i think that you want my well-being i
will interpret everything you say from
that angle the process shapes the
experience the form is more important
than the content this is like golden
rules if you want to write down the ten
you know and with that
comes the notion
that people fight over three things
primarily power and control
trust and closeness
respect and integrity
and once you know that you start to look
you don't listen for the noise and the
content especially when people have 20
years together you know there's a lot of
stories they can come back to you just
look what is it that they are really
fighting over
what do they experience from each other
at that moment is it about power is it
about trust or is it about recognition
see the interesting thing is that it's
not because you don't talk about
something that it doesn't exist
and if i go and i ask audiences all over
the world for the past since 2009 now
that i began the research on this book
how many of you have been affected by
the experience of infidelity
about 80 percent of the people raised
their hand
and that means that they were the
children of parents who were unfaithful
or the way the children who were born in
an affair in a love story really
or they were the siblings or they were
the friend that was consoling a broken
heart or they were the friends that was
listening to the confidences of someone
who is in the trolls of an affair or
they are the third in the triangle
it is systemic
but the topic of infidelity which has
been historically condemned is
historically practiced
shrouded in secrecy and shame
and hence kept very very silent
and unfortunately not helpful to the
thousands of people who grapple with it
so i've spent the last
years
working with hundreds of couples who've
been shattered by the experience of an
affair and of infidelity in the us and
abroad and i thought we can do better
so what's what's the definition of
infidelity then or how should we be
defining it is it thinking about
being with other people is it
flirting is it
what's the line what's the boundary
what's the definition so
the definition keeps on expanding that's
the first thing
it is no longer just because you got
pregnant from somebody else
with contraception today the definition
has become
is it watching porn
is it chatting
is it
a massage with happy endings
is it staying active on your dating apps
when you're already seeing somebody more
steadily
is it reconnecting with your exes on
facebook
it is actually rather unclear and it is
often left to the people to define it
but there are three
major elements that i think make it very
clearer for me anyway to define it the
first thing
is that it usually is organized around
the secret
the constitutive element of infidelity
is the secrecy
when it's not a secret when it's
consensual there it's a completely
different story so the secret is at the
heart of infidelity so when your partner
doesn't know or isn't aware that's right
then yes and of course that today
requires you to ask what must be shared
and what is private what is the extent
between privacy secrecy and transparency
then the second element is a certain
kind of emotional involvement to one
degree or another even if it's hit and
run
there still is an emotional involvement
it takes effort to make something mean
nothing
right
so
the the quality of that involvement
with the person with the sex with the
feelings that and then the third one
which is really the most important one
is that it's a sexual alchemy
the element of sexual alchemy is not sex
we know that most affairs are way less
about sex and a lot more about desire
now desire for what desire to be desired
desire to be seen to feel important to
have someone's attention someone who
cares about you desire to feel alive
decided to reconnect with lost parts of
yourself
way more important than the sex itself
the kiss that you only imagine giving
can be just as powerful as hours of
actual lovemaking
the mind is the most important sexual
organ
these treating secrecy emotional
involvement sexual alchemy
intersecting with each other
are the three central elements of what
makes infidelity but today
that we don't have religious
institutions necessarily telling us what
is the king of sins it is left to us
and our relationships to make sense of
this to define it to know where our
alliance will be with our partners to
know when we cross those lines and if
it's about thinking if it's about
remembering it's about fantasizing while
you're with your partner if it's
it is a
subject that is
deeply entrenched in our lives and often
very difficult for us
to
to open up and yet
we need to because
because we need to help people who
suffer with it the research says
basically 65
of startups don't succeed because of the
fallout between the co-founders this is
in case anybody cares if relationship
actually matters
um and you know it can be a three people
they sell they they still have to be
five years two of them don't talk
anymore the third one is watching this
debacle how do they handle this five
years is a long time to sit in such a
rut
or it can be you know two people who i
have started together one is constantly
looking for expansion the other one is
kind of you know slow slow you know we
don't have to and
some of them are partners in life and
some of them are just partners in
business but what you have in a
co-founder thing
is this
at the beginning for sure
it is passion for the project it is a
love affair
in which two people lose sense of time
lose sense of boundaries everything is
possible i mean it actually matches a
little bit the story of nascent love and
ness and passion and then you begin to
hit reality and then you have to deal
with the cycles of relationships harmony
disharmony repair or passion disillusion
rep reconnection however you want to
name it the same thing happens you're
dealing with issues of complementarity
instead of polarizing why do you do it
this way you realize that you actually
need that person to do it this way
because it's what gives you the
opportunity to do your thing and that
notion of working the complementarity is
the the juice of a mature relationship
and it's all of that that we work
that we work with when you hurt someone
nothing helps you more than the person
who hurt you to say to you i have
remorse and i feel guilty for hurting
you even if they don't feel guilt about
the experience of the affair itself
maybe you think that the affair was one
of the greatest things that you have
experienced in the philosophy
you've or you've been a mother and a
wife for the last seven years and you
haven't had a minute to think about
yourself and you felt like you had
completely died inside and for the first
time you reconnect with your own
sensuality and your own liveness and you
remember that you're more than just a
mother and just a wife for example
so you may think this was really
important to me
but nevertheless
what it meant to you and what it does to
your partner are two different things
so my acknowledging that remorse and
that guilt
is essential is the first step first
step yeah and that is very different
from feeling shame because when i feel
shame
and i feel so bad about myself i can't
believe i did this there's more
self-involvement right it's more about
like make yeah
you know make it about me so you can say
it's okay or whatever yeah yes i feel so
bad about myself that i can't feel bad
for what i did to you right right so i
have no empathy i still have not in the
empathy it's like you need to be able to
feel bad for making the other person
feel bad and that means that you can't
be so bad about you because then it's
all about you
big difference between shame and guilt
okay guilt is a relational
responsibility guilt is an
accountability to the other that's the
first one and the second thing is that i
then become the vigilante of the
relationship meaning that i for a while
while you are asking me the same
questions again and again because you're
trying to figure this out because your
whole reality has just been shattered
i am able to tell you it's okay i am
here just keep asking i'll answer you
i'm not going to say come on enough
already
let's move on let's move on it's over
don't you see it so no i cannot rush you
i have to give you the space to make
sense to be in your pain to hurt to get
angry to push me to pull me until we
slowly settle and there is a period like
that of that acute crisis that you just
can't push you have to go through it
because it is in the nature of the beast
people in a relationship by the way
especially when they come to couples
therapy you know i'm a couples and
family therapist primarily i'm a
systemically trained therapist i deal
with issues contextually
most of the time when people come to
couples therapy they don't come to say i
came to check myself out
couples therapy is often a drop-off
center you know they come to tell you
here he's my partner
what i think is the matter with that
person because i'm an expert on the
other person people stop looking at
themselves because they're completely
focused on what's wrong and what's off
and what's missing in the other
and the first thing you do in couples
therapy is you say to the people we're
gonna reach
reconfigure the lens
the day you come in
and you start the session by talking
about what you have done to improve
things or what you have done to
deteriorate things we're working my
father was illiterate okay my father and
my mother actually both of them came uh
to belgium by chance after each of them
being four and five years in
concentration camps in poland
uh they both were the sole survivors of
their entire family
they came with absolutely nothing they
were illegal refugees for five years
before they even became legalized
and my father always was a person who
said it doesn't matter how brilliant
they are or how rich they are what
matters the most is how decent they are
and when you are in a concentration camp
you get to see
the limits of a person's humanity and
the stretch and the outreach of a
person's humanity and their decency and
for some reason that always stayed with
me meaning don't get impressed
by all the appearances and by how
everything looks look at the person and
then he said and a friend is the person
who will always do more for themselves
as they for the other sorry as they will
do for themselves that's your friend
and check people out on that basis and
he had never read a book he couldn't
read and write pretty much he read the
newspaper he spoke five languages but
poorly
and and he was a grand human being and i
often often think of him in relation to
that especially when i come into the
entrepreneurial world which is often a
world of inflated self there is a
phenomenal crossing of parallel tracks
that is happening currently on the one
hand
a matching set of expectations you know
when you come to personal life romantic
life the expectations that you would
have with one person what once an entire
community used to provide the same
person is going to give us security and
stability and dependability and
reliability and predictability and the
same person is going to give us awe and
mystery and passion and novelty and
excitement and danger and fill in the
bucket
this dual set of needs like that that
you know for most of history marriage
was for survival
then we brought in the companionship
romantic element and now we want
relationships for self-actualization
well the same thing is happening at work
you know you don't just and you know you
go to work and you don't plan to spend
20 years there and work your way up step
by step you know the wall street journal
had an article i just read yesterday it
was called quitters are winners it's
like the more you leave the faster you
grow kind of thing and the more you're
gonna get better jobs and this notion
that after two years something has to
happen and if you you know
used to say that you leave you left
marriages if you were very unhappy and
today you leave them if you think you
could be happier but the same thing
happens with a job you don't leave the
job you know because they close the
factory you leave the job because you
don't feel that you have been promoted
properly and fast enough and that
rising
on the maslow ladder of needs you know
that notion that it's about
self-actualization about identity
formation about belonging the fact that
we bring to love market economy and we
talk about having a good deal in our
relationships but we bring two relations
to work a language and a vocabulary of
relationships we talk about authenticity
belonging empathy trust
when was that the bottom line language
of business there is no incentivized
system as in the in the private domain
so people just think why bother right
and that's the difference is that the
ones who have good relationships are the
ones who created their own internal
incentive incentivized system what are
some of those incentive systems that
you've seen over time that really work
or effective for
long-term relationships
i would say the first thing is almost
one of the first things that our parents
teach you please and thank you
do you know how many people stop
thanking their partners
thank you thank you for doing this for
me thank you for picking up the shirts
thank you for you know making you feel
appreciated yes appreciation
appreciation is huge
gratitude acknowledgement of the
presence of the other in your life
not did you do this
did you call did you pick up do this you
know half the time expectations
expectations of course you know
expectations is often a resentment in
the make
it's like with the expectation comes the
fear of it's not good
thank person first of all and because it
also makes it feel like this is not a
given nobody owes you squat you're not
owed anything you're not that important
you're actually quite replaceable trust
is something that gets cultivated over
time through tests and experiences
together with other people of course
this has changed because we have a
shared economy in which we are trusting
total strangers with our home and our
most precious belongings
so the whole definition of trust is
shifting
but it's difficult to have a feeling of
belonging when you don't stay long
enough or to have a feeling of belonging
when you're hired by the day and by the
hour because it suits the numbers of the
company
and every book these days about
relationships is going to talk about
belonging or the lack thereof and about
loneliness or the isolation and the lack
of connection
this is the two main subjects that
everybody is talking about
partly because when you dismantle a
system like the one that we had and you
introduce a new social system you can
become evangelical about it you can be
very happy about all the changes
but
you have to deal with the consequences
of the changes
and one of the things that dan siegel
was talking about so beautifully
yesterday is that an individual
a body a society a relationship needs to
regulate itself and one of the main
thing we regulate ourselves on is
between stability and change
between chaos and
rigidity between the past and the future
when we have too much change going on
all at once we become ontologically
anxious or anguished
because we can't catch up
which is partly what is happening now
and what has been propelled in the last
year
by the new president of this country and
by the new presidents of a bunch of
other countries and by the metoo
movement
it's a unique educational opportunity
but it makes a lot of people very
nervous the truth is this there's only
two relationships
that resemble each other the one you
have with your parents or the people who
raise you
and the one you have with the people you
fall in love with
people can sit in my office all the time
and say i have this with no one else i
don't have this with anybody at work
nobody among my friends ever thinks like
that you're the only one who speaks like
this or thinks this about me or with
whom i do this
no
you're the only one and now we go back
in history and i'm sorry to be the
psychologist but that's really
it is the place where we often learned
about closeness trust loyalty commitment
sharing
taking receiving asking all these
essential verbs of relationships we
learned that at home we also learned
jealousy and possessiveness vengeance
you name them the beauty and the not
beauty yeah we saw it all as children
right we saw the fights we saw the love
we saw the you know we saw the coldness
the lack of intimacy and the intimacy
yes yes and we bring that with us and we
often promise ourselves i'll never be
this one i'll never be this way i'll
never talk like this i'll you know and
we find ourselves often much closer to
the apple
and i'm presenting ourselves to the tree
we resent ourselves we're like how do we
do that well why do we get this place
and then we feel ashamed about it and
since we don't like to feel ashamed
about it we hide it and one of the way
we hide it is we blame the partner
that's just one of the ways we are very
resourceful in not owning ourselves
right exactly as you've worked with all
different people through these
relationships is there a sort of like
common mark or common marks of
successful relationships yeah come up
time and time again yeah yeah yeah you
know
i'm a couples therapist and i don't know
if you know but in couples therapy
rarely do people come to tell you what
they have done wrong
they don't really come to tell you
what's the matter with them they come to
a drop-off center and they come to tell
me this is my partner you know i will be
the expert on what's wrong with that
person and fix it
um i think by definition relationships
that do well are relationships where
people take responsibility for their
share without being mired in shame for
it
and it's so it's safe to take
responsibility safe to own your stuff
and people have a sense that you know if
you want to change the other you change
yourself i always had a clear sense that
my life was not going to be small sure
my life has to be big big doesn't mean
successful and money big meant
meaningful rich layered
you know it's not necessarily well known
or famous but
feeling
for free yeah not dead not dead i mean
there's a reason i write about eroticism
right and that sense that i was not
going to be mediocre
you know i'm not content with just the
average of something that it has to be
not the best it has to be the right one
for me at that moment that may be the
beautiful spot or the the right friend
to be with or or the right act to take
in relation to somebody or to some cause
but that sense that my life has to be
big stand up
if you
if you have been blessed by having a
mentor in the realm of relationships
wow
nice
nice because i don't want to ask if
you've had mentors in your business
lives because everybody will be standing
this iniquity between having models for
how you do business but not having
enough models for how you live your
relationships needs to change
it really is foundational
and i you know some of you it may be
your parents and some of you it may be
the neighbor and some of you it may be
somebody that you actually never even
met
but it is absolutely clear that having a
mentor in the realm of relationship is
essential for people to have something
that they can aspire to and emulate
so take a moment for those of you who
stand
and thank them
and then make also mental note if you
actually have ever told them
and if you haven't it's a good idea
and don't wait till they're on their
dead bed
and if you don't
then just ask yourself who who could you
reach out to who would be someone to
whom you could talk about that part of
your life it is not okay that therapists
like me are often the only people to
hear the stories and the truth
and especially now it's fake news on
social media where everybody has to
parade their joyous happy lives
nobody has any idea of what's happening
in the lives of others your best friends
can come and break up and you didn't
even see it coming
i would say
relational intelligence starts with
relational self-awareness
if you don't have it vis-a-vis you it's
very hard to suddenly start to listen to
others if you are self-critical it's
going to be hard to listen to other
people say things without hearing them
criticizing you i mean it's an extension
so
um
that doesn't mean it's just you know
this concept of you should love yourself
first and no we learn to love ourselves
because we are loved by others this
doesn't happen out of context it's a
both end but there is something about a
certain kind of awareness you know one
of the great levels of awareness has to
do with two major distortions i'm sure
not some of you have never done this but
i have so one of them is this
confirmation bias i have a view right i
could be here and say this woman is here
to have a great conversation with me and
i am
in there with her and i'm gonna enjoy
this or i can have this notion this
woman and all the people who interview
you they're always out to get you you
know they just want to make you look
stupid and i am going to interpret every
one of your questions with my
confirmation bias yeah i'm going to look
for evidence that reinforces how i see
myself and how i see the world relating
to me that is a major trap and the
second one is if you're if i'm in a bad
mood i will think that it's because you
know there was traffic and and i the
circumstances of my day made me in a bad
mood but if you are in a bad mood it's
because you're a nasty person you know
mine is circumstantial yours is
characterological
you know the world is clear
it's important to have a sense of how
how do we map relationships i think
sometimes the world is kind of
mystifying and in fact relationships are
quite structured systems you know in
which you straddle two main axes
structure
hierarchy power discipline
all the way down to chaos and
relatedness from very close to very far
distant and disengaged pretty much most
relationships can be tracked there but
now you take your team and you look
how are we working here is this a very
hierarchical very set system nothing can
happen you have to go through ten
different people change is impossible
etc etc but it's very warm because we
have a lot of closeness and it's it's
camaraderie but very inefficient or is
it very distant rather cold but actually
very structured and very efficient but
not very loving
you can map that and then you begin to
see what are the attributes that we have
ample of and what are the ones that need
to be reinforced and who can do that who
can bring the pieces that the other
people may not necessarily have so that
you create a real diversity that isn't
only
about gender and race and background but
it is actually about relational
capacities
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible lisa nichols motivation check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there like i was hungry
people often want to call me the
exception like oh my god you're the
exception no i'm not the exception i'm
an average ordinary woman who chose
every day to make one more extraordinary
decision